You might be wondering what this rectangle has to do with this expression. Well,
really the multiplication of this factor, and this factor, represents the total
area inside a rectangle. We know this answer should be x squared and 2x, or x
squared plus 2x, you would have to add these two areas together to get the total
area. If we distribute the x to each term on the inside of the parenthesis. We
would have x times x, which is x squared, and x times 2 which is positive 2x. If
we list the sum of the terms to represent the total area, we've really found the
multiplication of 2 factors. Some students have trouble remembering x times x is
x squared, sometimes I think it's 2x. But we know that can't be the case because
if we have x by x or x times x, we formed a square or x squared. I hope this is
a powerful visual for you to remember x times x is always x squared.